la crise du coronavirus exercent
beaucoup de pression sur les épiciers
actuellement les gens consomment plus
fort des réserves aussi pour respecter
les consignes du gouvernement alors
franck hainaut est co propriétaire de
l'intermarché boyer à montréal membre de
l'association des détaillants en
alimentation bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
fillion quelles sont les conséquences
pour vous de cette augmentation quand
même soudaine qu'on a vu dans les
derniers jours d'achats des
consommateurs va écouter d'abord je
tiens à préciser que on ne mourra pas de
faim au québec faut le répéter les
épiceries ont fait face à un achalandage
incroyable démesurée et on est après se
replacer les tablettes vont se remplir
graduellement
bon maintenant cette demande 7,7 de
bandes importante fait en sorte que
c'est toujours l'offre et la demande
oui on va sapeurs ont sapé reçoit déjà
actuellement que sur certains items et
bien il ya trop de demandes
vous avez si demain il ya un ouragan en
floride ou en californie
le prix des agrumes va augmenter bon ben
on vit quelque chose qui est planétaire
et si on prend peut-être l'exemple de
l'espagne qui nous fournit beaucoup
d'agrumes mais l'espagne ne va pas bien
on est tout au courant et les
producteurs espagnols ne produisent pas
comme il devrait produire donc à partir
de là il ya une rareté du produit est
forcément des produits qui arrivent
d'espagne est en plus rares le prix
augmente
we are on le constate déjà
particulièrement sur les agrumes
il y avait ce matin quasiment
vous donner une idée des caisses
d'orange qu'on pouvait négocier la
semaine passée à 21 dollars et et a29 ce
matin bon par contre il va y avoir aussi
une insulte une incidence sur les
producteurs de floride qui eux aussi
sont très demandés de pas parce que je
crois qu'il ya pas juste les québécois
qui font beaucoup de réserve
je crois que c'est mondiale alors cette
demande pour bell s'est répercutée aussi
surtout ses fournisseurs de floride et
de californie oh je m'aperçois voler
quand tu as loupé son passé de 12 à 24
dollars la caisse maintenant alors je la
relis aussi et donc est ce que ça veut
dire que ça fait votre prix d'achat
alors que vous me donnez aussi le prix à
l'import tu as fait c'est votre
le prix d'achat et donc le prix à la
vente va augmenter le prix à la vente va
forcément dans les semaines à venir
éventuellement manquer mais je crois
aussi que comme consommateur et comme
épicier on a un rôle à jouer
c'est de consommer d'abord ce qui qui
est local avant tout et aussi de tout
simplement ne pas acheter ces produits
là en ce qui me concerne comme épicier
si je m'aperçois qu'il ya des produits
qui sont absolument fou comme bree je ne
vais pas les acheter parce que si je les
mets en tablette
je ne les vendrai pas et je vais les
jeter contrat alors on va mais les
grenats blida et fort les cantalous et
les les oranje dont vous parlez là vous
en avez acheté je présume que vous allez
les ventes bon bah regarder justement ce
qu'on a fait ce matin en a bloqué
plusieurs palettes pour à peu près 3 4
semaines d'inventaire d'agrumes
ça m'a permis d'aller je ne suis
certainement pas le seul d'avoir fait ça
au québec mais ça nous permet de
garantir à nos clients un prix pour les
quatre semaines parce qu'encore une fois
ce que nous vivons actuellement c'est du
jamais vu
bon on croise tous les doigts pour que
les dans quatre semaines ça aille mieux
et puis on vit aussi des situations au
jour le jour on écrit notre histoire
vous allez on se lève le matin qu'on
sait pas ce qu'on va vivre mais bon par
exemple comme je disais mots ce que j'ai
fait j'en achète plus on sait que des
agrumes c'est un peu comme des pommes ou
des pommes de terre ça se conserve et ça
va me permettre d'assurer un service et
surtout de deux lits
id une augmentation dans mon magasin et
je crois que toutes les grandes
bannières vont faire à peu près la même
chose
est-ce que voulez vous me parlez des
agrumes mais est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
produits comme ça ou vous constatez qui
aura des hausses de prix faute il a
faut-il s'attendre à des hausses de prix
sur plusieurs produits et quels types de
produits
écoutez je crois que chacun a remarqué
qu'on était au printemps c'est du moins
la fin de l'hiver
on n'a pas de produits locaux comme tel
alors forcément si et des régions de par
la planète qui sont extrêmement touchées
par le coc u19 faut s'attendre à ce que
les productions soient moindres est que
les prix augmentent de ce fait là ce
matin - ya eu d une petite envolée au
niveau de certaines salades
bon bah qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a
switché sur d'autres variétés de salades
c'est un peu ça aussi note à note notre
hall d'épicier mais effectivement c'est
ce que vous devez le travail c'est votre
travail aussi de bien sélectionner de
préparer votre clientèle ou de protéger
votre clientèle des hausses de prix
absolument absolument parce que je crois
que les épiciers et surtout toutes les
équipes dans les épiceries font une job
absolument fantastique depuis cinq jours
ils sont au front ils répondent que des
mots je peux parler de mon équipe c'est
absolument fantastique
oui absolument là dessus c'est clair les
nos chiffres ont augmenté mais le but
avant tout c'est de répondre à la
demande c'est de donner un bon service
moi je disais ce matin au gérant oui on
fait des bonnes affaires mais il faut
aussi que nos clients à la fin de cette
crise parce qu'il y aura une fin nous
disent merci merci vous avez été là
quand on avait besoin de vous et vous
nous avez bien servi et je crois que
c'est ce que 99% des épiciers québécois
font actuellement êtes vous inquiet pour
les producteurs locaux très très inquiet
parce que vous n'en parlez aux gens
tendaient tantôt avant la
un commentaire vous savez c'est le temps
des semis beaucoup de travailleurs
mexicains arrive habituellement au
québec pour aider et ils ne vont pas
être là définitivement
c'est quelque chose qui peut à moyen
terme avoir une incidence sur les prix
ce soit en ontario et au québec et je
crois que ça c'est quelque chose qui le
gouvernement doit regarder vip et
rapidement parce que je sais c'est
quelque chose qui va faire plus si on a
pas je vous donne un exemple de san
fermin à québec nous serons obligés de
les acheter au chili et ses passagers
des solutions franck hanoh merci
beaucoup je vous remercie bonne foi